[Musique]
avec voire même charrier bonjour Armelle
bonjour les Ukrainiens ont subi une
pluie de bombes hier matin et opération
punitive menée par la Russie après
l'explosion du pont de Crimée le
week-end dernier quel peut-être la
réponse des Occidentaux la réponse des
Occidentaux elle passe d'abord par plus
d'armements c'est la seule capacité que
l'Occident a aujourd'hui
a pour dire à l'Ukraine parce que il ne
peut pas déclarer une guerre à la Russie
il y a toujours ce coup près de l'arme
atomique qui reste aussi une priorité
savoir comment est-ce que on évite cette
dernière j'allais dire encoche ou
Vladimir Poutine se retrouverait en
position de devoir se défendre avec une
bombe tactique donc l'armement ça reste
une des rares solutions qu'on puisse
avoir en mettant du coup un armement
plus adapté à ce qui s'est passé hier
qui est une offensive très large puisque
on a tapez des villes qui vont donner ça
à carquif qui vont donner pro qui est
plutôt au centre à Kiev la capitale et
qui vont jusqu'à live qui est la ville
qui est la plus proche de la Pologne
donc il faudrait mettre un bouclier
aérien il faudrait pouvoir arrêter les
missiles quand ils sont envoyés ce qui a
eu lieu en partie quand les Russes on
voit des missiles de croisière c'est pas
le missile qui va le plus vite mais
enfin il faut du coup aussi avoir un
armement adapté alors on a eu des aides
à l'armement ukrainien qui était assez
colossal on l'a vu sur le terratre qui
ont permis la contre-offensive mais là
on s'adapte à autre chose simplement ça
coûte de l'argent il faut en avoir les
Américains puisent aussi maintenant dans
leur j'allais dire dans ce qu'ils ont
ils ne peuvent pas écorner leur stock
stratégique alors il y a en ce moment
donc cet assemblée générale des Nations
unies réunies en urgence à New York
réunion qui était prévue avant les
frappes russes hier sur la Russie
toutefois comme un par mimétisme la
Russie a réuni son propre Conseil de
sécurité de son côté est-ce que ça
permet de savoir que clairement quelle
est la feuille de route de Vladimir
Poutine ça permet en tout cas d'avoir un
affichage plus politique pour Vladimir
Poutine il a été suivi des déclarations
par Medef aussi derrière pour dire que
de toute manière la guerre il
l'amènerait jusqu'au bout côté russe
maintenant et que c'est une guerre qui
touche évidemment à l'Ukraine parce que
c'est sur ce territoire là qu'on est en
train de se passer mais que derrière il
y a l'Occident on connaît ce qu'il avait
déjà dit et puis ils ont même rappelé
comment est-ce que les campagnes
napoléoniennes s'est déterminée pour
dire regardez à un moment donné vous
pouvez aussi vous embourber donc on
savait que Vladimir Poutine avait été
critiquée entre autres par ces ceux qui
sont plus à droite en disant il faut
être plus fort il faut être plus violent
avec avec les Ukrainiens les choix hier
de taper sur un maximum de villes
montrent effectivement qu'il y a cette
volonté là et donc on espère simplement
effectivement qu'on va encore accélérer
le président
biélorus qui jusque là dans le pays
était jusque là une base arrière des
troupes russes a dit qu'à présent une
excluait pas d'entrer concrètement en
guerre qu'est ce que ça peut changer
alors ça peut changer quelque chose
parce que si il y a une guerre qui menée
par ce front qui sera dans ce cas-là le
front nord pour les Ukrainiens ce sera
certainement le front de trop on les
voit ils se sont occupés là pour
l'instant sur l'Est ils sont un peu plus
vers le sud aussi vers Kerson donc s'il
y a la Biélorussie en plus ça
compliquera beaucoup les choses on est
aussi sur une armée
ukrainienne qui même si elle a beaucoup
d'armements même si elle était
galvanisée par les dernières victoires
et que le pont de la Crimée par exemple
a certainement fait beaucoup de bien au
moral des Ukrainiens il n'en reste pas
moins que la démo qu'elle a des blessé
et que maintenant c'est depuis mois de
février quel combat donc il y a aussi
une fatigue et ça il faut le comprendre
d'autant plus qu'on est sur une
situation où on sait qu'on va aller
ensuite faire une zone hivernale mais là
on va voir quelques semaines qui vont
être les fameuses semaines il y a de la
boue et donc où c'est très compliqué de
combattre donc les Russes ont intérêt à
avancer leurs pions au maximum après ce
qui reste à savoir c'est la faisabilité
de la chose c'est savoir est-ce que
Lucas and Co laissera faire de combien
d'hommes disposera-t-on et cetera et
cetera mais on voit qu'il y a cette axes
là qui reste le plus dangereux et
l'autre axe qui reste aussi très
dangereux c'est le choix des
bombardements quand on voit par exemple
que Vladimir Poutine a ciblé très
précisément des centrales qui fabriquent
de l'électricité des centrales
thermiques ou même des représentations
de l'Union européenne ou des bureaux
d'administration
ukrainiennes qui ça aussi peut faire
monter d'un cran les difficultés en
Ukraine merci beaucoup Armel c'était
votre décryptage